هجوم اوكراني مضاد وان لم يكن بحجم
التوقعات الا انه بدا ياتي بثماره تدريجيا
هذا التقدم والتفوق المعاكس وفقا هنا
لصحيفه
الفرنسيه له عده اسباب ابرزها تفوق
الاسلحه الغربيه التي بحوزه الاوكرانيين
على تلك التي بيدروس ولا سيما المناظير
الليليه والاسلحه التي تعمل ليلا وتحقق
طبعا نتائج دقيقه بحسب الصحيفه وهو ما دفع
بالاوكرانيين لاتباع استراتيجيه الهجوم
ليلا لتقليل فاعليه القوات الجويه الروسيه
وتجنب الهجمات من الطائرات بدون طيار وفقا
هنا ايضا للصحيفه الفرنسيه بدوره معهد
دراسه الحرب الامريكيه اكد بان
الاوكرانيين صعدوا من هجماتهم الليليه
مستفيدين من قدرات الاسلحه الغربيه على
حساب ما يملكه طبعا الروس من اسلحه كما ان
الحلفاء الغربيين بالدبابات القتاليه
والمدرعات وايضا الاسلحه المتطوره بشكل
متزايد في الاونه الاخيره يمكن انه هو
عامل وفر مزايا استراتيجيه خطيره الاكياس
في ساحه المعركه بدورهم اشار مسؤولون في
البنتاجون بان الفريق الافضل بالجيش
الاوكراني هو اللواء السابع والاربعون
الذي تم تدريبه بحسب هؤلاء في دول الناتو
وهو مجهز بمعدات وتقنيات حديثه ما قد يلعب
دورا هاما خلال الفتره المقبله بحسب طبعا
مسؤولون
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات